let's compare five six and five eighths
let's think about what they mean
five six means five out of six pieces if
you have a whole let's say a whole cake
and you cut it into six pieces five six
is five of those six pieces five eighths
again is five pieces that's something
that's the same we're both talking about
five pieces but this time we split our
cake into eight pieces so it's five out
of eight pieces we can represent that by
drawing it maybe we can draw here's one
whole and then another one so these are
two equal holes and on one of them we
can shade five six and the other five
eight that way we can look and compare
them so four five six if we divide this
whole we were using the example of cake
into six equal sized pieces not sure if
those are perfect but let's say those
are six equal sized pieces
five six is talking about five of those
pieces so one two three four five this
image represents five six now four five
eight let's think about it for a second
well the piece is in five eighths be
bigger or smaller than five six are
eight bigger or smaller than six well we
can draw and see if we have the same
size hole which we need to have the same
size hole and we draw and we split it
into eight pieces this time so now we
have fourths and eight these pieces
these eighths one eighth is smaller than
a six because this time we had to split
the cake between eight people so we got
smaller pieces now again we can shade
five of them seems like five pieces
might be equal to five pieces but we can
look and see four
five and now we can look and see the
five six takes up more space takes up
more area this is a larger amount and
the reason is because each six each
piece is larger so five larger pieces is
more than five smaller pieces or is
greater than and remember with our
symbol the open side the larger side
should be facing our larger number so
five six is greater than five eighths
here's one more but this time let's try
to compare them without drawing let's
just think about what these mean two
fifths means two pieces out of five so
one hole will split five ways and we got
two of the pieces two thirds needs that
same hole we'll split three ways and we
got two of the pieces well which two
pieces are larger the two thirds are
larger because if we only have to split
our pieces three ways we can have larger
pieces so the two fifths are smaller
these two smaller pieces are less these
two smaller pieces are less than the two
larger pieces and again the open end of
our symbol should be facing the larger
number so two fifths is less than two
thirds